I the other day, uh, during our story about
chicken sandwiches at Popeye's, that it's
been like 18 years since I went to a fast
food restaurant. Here is a very specific question
from a viewer left by voicemail. At two, one
nine two, David p about my fast food hiatus.
Take a listen.
Hey David, you mentioned that you haven't
had any fast moves 10 or 15 years. I wanted
to know if you would consider fast casual
food like chipotle lay or five guys fresh
city. Um, maybe [inaudible] good as fast food
or you know, do you partake in those when
you're dining out in a hurry? Thanks. Bye.
What was it? It's not [inaudible] it has a
name. It's fast casual again. Is that a corporate
s a a focus group name? Fast casual instead
of fast food. Makes it sound better in some
way. Um, I, I don't, I don't go to those places
either. I, uh, go to, I'm trying to think
when I flew through, I believe it's Washington
Dulles. There's like, I think in the international
terminal, at least last time I was there,
there was nothing other than a chipotle a.
So I did get a grilled chicken Burrito at
chipotle a, that was probably eight years
ago. Um, but now I just don't go to any of
those places. I'm lucky enough to live in
places and mostly be in places, big cities,
and also kind of like hipstery small towns,
you know, Portland, Maine, Burlington, Vermont,
western Massachusetts, La, San Francisco,
Boston, Miami.
These are all places where you just never
need to go to any of these chains. You usually,
there are just local options that are much
better. Um, so no, I don't really go to the
fast casual places. I don't really go to any
of them unless it is an emergency. Although
a, actually, here's a story. When I was flying
back from Aruba last week, the Aruban airport
is a disaster does, I think it took nearly
two hours of just going through different
lines to finally get to my gate. And the only
thing available in the international gate
area where I was waiting was a Subarc [inaudible].
So I went to Sobero and got a slice of pizza
and it was vile. I mean, just absolutely vile.
So anyway, now I avoid the entire thing. We've
got a great bonus show for you today. Get
instant access by becoming a member, right?
Join pacman.com or a patron at patrion.com/david
Paxton show. Fantastic bonus show coming up.
Well, you could that [inaudible]
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.